All right, we're going to start this week's
covid update a little differently than we
usually do, we'll start globally and then
work into the US instead of starting with
the United States, because right now, the
global context is increasingly important to
figure out what's going on, because globally,
cases are actually almost at a peak right
now where we are almost at a pandemic high
globally with about 600, 75000 cases per day,
which is close to the absolute highest point
we had was about 745 thousand cases per day.
So thanks to just huge spikes in some countries
and then small spikes in others, we are of
all of this time going all the way back to
whenever we're calling the beginning February
of 2020 or really even earlier, although we
didn't know the number of cases at that time,
we are essentially close to the global peak
of cases right now.
Now, it's important to understand that as
more people get vaccinated, cases will mean
less and less in the sense that a covid case
will less and less likely be something that
results in a hospitalization or results in
a death as more and more people are vaccinated.
But the important thing to understand is that
globally, we are nowhere near that point in
time.
Right now, of the world's roughly eight billion
people, only seven hundred and eighty eight
million doses have been administered.
And since some of those, you know, are two
shot regimens, under one percent of the global
population has been vaccinated right now.
So for now, a global case, spike does mean
more deaths eventually.
The cases right now are highest in India,
Turkey, here in the United States, in Brazil,
in France and Poland.
Those are the top six right now.
So that is the global context, what's happening
here in the United States.
Well, let's now take a look.
Cases in the United States sort of level,
a slight uptick bottomed out around 55000
a day.
Now back up to about 65000 cases per day.
So we are simply in a fight right now.
It's variance.
And young people going crazy against vaccines.
And we'll talk, by the way, in the next segment
about what's going on with the Johnson and
Johnson vaccine, which which is going to be
paused at this point in time.
We'll get to that.
But you have places like Michigan and in the
northeast of the United States, with the more
contagious British variant increasingly dominant,
more and more young people getting the virus.
And you've got that up against more and more
vaccinations that fortunately are being done.
The good news is that this entire time and
deaths have continued to decline.
When what was it?
Six weeks ago, we saw the case decline level.
We said we might see deaths level out in three
weeks as well.
That hasn't happened.
Deaths peaked in mid to late January, around
3500 people dying per day.
Just inconceivable tragedy now down to a still
tragic but about 80 percent lower, 750 deaths
per day.
That should continue to decline as vaccination
is rolling out.
We have not yet vaccinated enough people to
see cases collapse.
We are vaccinating enough older and at risk
folks that increasingly people getting the
virus are less and less likely to die.
And that's exactly why you start with the
oldest and the most vulnerable some states.
And this is good news.
And then we'll get to what's going on with
JNJ in a moment.
Some states are only about a month out from
herd immunity.
Massachusetts is a state, for example, where
92 percent of the population wants the vaccine.
More than one percent of the population is
being vaccinated daily, approaching high 30s.
Percent vaccinated and could be at 70 percent
within 30 to 40 days.
Now, for comparison, when Israel got to 50
percent vaccinated, cases just fell off a
cliff went down very, very quickly.
So that could be coming in some states.
In other states like Mississippi, vaccination
is happening really slowly, not nearly as
much interest in the vaccine, many unscheduled,
you know, appointments in Mississippi that
are just remaining unscheduled and available.
So it remains to be seen what happens there.
Now, as far as vaccination, we saw another
single day record of four point six million
doses on Saturday, nearly another three point
six million doses on Sunday.
These are really incredible numbers.
So the playbook is keep vaccinating anyone
at risk that you can convince as.
To the importance of getting vaccinated, that's
great.
And then don't go crazy just yet, we know
that the Phizer vaccine is less effective
against the South African variant.
The vaccines work well against the British
variant, basically just as well.
But it is more contagious.
So that's that's quite literally a race.
The path out is vaccination.
Likely boosters in the fall or winter modified
for the variants.
That's where we are.
So we have to keep going at this point.
Most people I know personally have had at
least one shot, even younger people.
Full eligibility happening nationwide on April
19th.
That's in six days.
That's all great.
The problem now is what's going on with the
Johnson and Johnson vaccine.
So we should talk about
that next.